okay so I should definitely be doing all
the other things I need to do but this
is way too much fun on the video that I
did recently on the symbolic versus
literal interpretation of the Bible I
got a very good and concise comment
about atheism and why many people have
abandoned religion I have some sympathy
for atheism in many ways mostly because
many religious people have done a
dreadful job at explaining things and
have alienated generations of smart
people and also because atheists often
become that way through curiosity and a
desire to have an integrated worldview I
mean when you face literalists religious
types there's a kind of blind
unconsciousness that is truly nauseating
I once confronted a literalist type and
when I asked him when it says in the
Bible that Christ was taken up into
heaven where exactly did he go into the
atmosphere to the moon and that person
had actually never thought about that
had never asked themselves that question
so yeah
sympathy for atheists so I'm gonna read
the comment which is by user named Amber
trance and I'm gonna try to answer as
best as I can quote I am an atheist
because my pure and honest desire to
understand the universe led me to
answers from biology physics and other
scientific fields these answers are more
sublime and precious than anything I
know I believe religions and symbolism
can confer meaning in one's personal
subjective life because I've been on
that path before you could say that that
is enough because all we have in our
existence is our subjective point of
view what I believe it's a noble act to
care less about that and to desire to
know what happens in the universe
outside your own personal life then how
could anyone judge you for being an
atheist when science as imperfect as it
is brought knowledge about distant stars
and galaxies the small world of atoms
and much more mysticism and religion did
not enlighten us about matters above
subjective and social aspects many other
things can replace religion mysticism
and symbolism in creating a stable and
moral society the valley that science
brought to humanity on the other side is
irreplaceable I will cease being an
atheist and become spiritual or whatever
when all these pretty post hoc
connections and symbols will make a
difference and allowing me to understand
the nature of the universe outside my
insignificant tiny life all right
that's actually a pretty good that's
actually pretty good and I and I hope I
chose a comment that most atheists would
find represents a typical journey which
would lead one to atheism and to be fair
that's a pretty generous statement many
atheists might be far more acid in their
vision of the symbolic language so there
are a lot of things some tango but here
we go
symbolism and religious language is not
just about the subjective and social and
symbolism is indeed a language
describing what happens in the universe
so then why might you ask is it so
different from modern science well the
answer often given by atheist is that
it's just a less advanced system of what
science is trying to deal with we know
more today and so we can correct the
mistake our ancestors made so if we take
for granted that religious language were
there to describe the world in a
technical sense the same way modern
science is attempting to do then yes
modern science has a more let's say
accurate and exact description of net of
nature's of natural laws and events but
I think to assume that is ill informed
and maybe even a bit ill-intentioned for
if one compares apples to oranges and
insists that they are the same while
constantly mocking the orange for being
a queer regressive and inadequate Apple
well there's something that's wrong
so so then how do we account for the
difference between the two well maybe
something like this symbolism and
religious language in general are an
attempt to understand the universe yes
but also while simultaneously
understanding the process by which we
understand the universe okay so let me
repeat that in another way it's both a
description of the world and a
description of how it is I can describe
the world so in relation to modern
science religious language would be
something like something of a meta
process or a meta language because it
tries to express the thing it is
focusing on let's say a mountain okay
while also expressing the process by
which that focus is even possible
so if modern science can describe a
mountain height with terrain it's you
know it's foliage it's mineral
Constitution religious language is
expressing why I have a category like
mountain in the first place why that
category is relevant to humans basically
what does a mountain mean so the
scientists mover towards something like
this will return something like a
mountain doesn't mean anything but to
say so is to ignore the human variable
ignore that we are the ones looking at
the mountain even if I believe that that
mountain is outside of my tiny existence
it ignores consciousness ignores why I
would bother to have a category like
mountain it ignores that I have to climb
a mountain or go around a mountain what
it's in my way it ignores the effect
going up a mountain has on human
consciousness all those things are real
there are no more illusions than the
scientific data symbolism tries to take
all of that into account that is disco
some mountain without pretending that we
are not human beings living in a world
of mountains so it does have a personal
and social aspect to it because it takes
into account consciousness but is it but
it isn't just personal and social and
also taking consciousness into account
does it mean that it's a relative thing
and subjective in the way that we see
that word today subjective in the sense
of idiosyncratic arbitrary to my own
particularities and proclivities there's
a universal aspect to the experience of
a mountain so the religious language is
above the scientific language and
contains the scientific process within
it makes it possible and I know that
that jordan peterson has mentioned this
a few times but he hasn't had the
opportunity yet to elaborate completely
how that works in his talks and i know
it's hard to understand and it will seem
aggravating beyond belief
too many atheists at the outset but so
i'm gonna try to give an example that
will unpack this as much as possible so
i think we can keep going with the
mountain i talked about mountains before
another talks but it's such a basic
image that it can help us understand
many things there are reasons why
mountains are often sacred so the
experience of a mountain is that as you
ascend the mountain the width of the
base is refined it necessarily gets
narrower narrower and narrower as you go
higher and higher the experience of
particularity is contained more and more
because as you go up the mountain you
can see more and more you can see
further it's when you're at the bottom
of the mountain you can only see the
very particular the rocks
in front of you the trees around you but
as you ascend your gaze widens and you
get more and more of an encompassing
experience this refinement of experience
happens as the mountain itself becomes
narrower and narrower moves from the
particular and the many to the one and
the universal so reaching the summit
then your view opens up completely in a
kind of a jump because suddenly as you
reach the summit in that very moment the
entire world seems to appear beneath you
and you can see the mountain itself on
all its sides and the route the horizon
all around you so that experience of the
mountain the one I've just described is
the same as any hierarchy so let's take
the Army for example the men are at the
bottom and get specific order specific
tasks but as you go up the military
hierarchy the corporals the generals are
less and less in terms of quantity there
are more men and less leaders and then
they also have a more global vision of
strategy and each level contains the
explicit actions of the lower levels
within them so let's say the men have to
dig this trench transport things to this
outpost the higher levels contain that
within the more implicit strategies
let's say reinforcing that front
defending these assets until one ascends
when reaches let's say the top general
where the patterns of the battle are set
up with the final goal in mind outflank
the opponent take this city win the war
so similarly the same hierarchy will
have a conception of conceptual
equivalent so for example specific
species of something let's say a
Dalmatian a greyhound or a Pekinese
despite their
differences can be contained in a higher
concept which is dog which can be that
contained and regulated by higher and
higher concepts canine mate mammal
animal and then being so what the
language of symbolism does is suggests
that there is a structural relationship
between all these different versions of
the hierarchy that they exhibit the same
truth and so are connected in a manner
which has absolutely nothing to do with
the kind of quantitative analysis of
science and everything to do with
language and consciousness so Christ is
the head of the church
just like our physical head is the
symbolic head of our body that is
certainly not a scientifically valid
statement so now we're going to take it
one step further what happens is this
symbolism religious symbolism is exactly
that ladder it's exactly that mountain
it offers images at the base of the
mountain the most particular images
possible these act as a kind of support
for the higher levels of meaning so
symbolism is always very concrete very
immediate a tree a rock the earth the
heavens but the structural patterns then
move you up towards more Universal and
encompassing realities now most of all
we need to understand that this mountain
this ascent is also an ascent of
consciousness because we human beings
are organized in the same way we have
these desires and and multiplicities on
our edges these competing personalities
which pull us here and there tend to to
pull us apart pull us in
to multiplicity but as we ascend our own
consciousness we find a Center the head
or the mind the church fathers speak of
the noose and that centre of
consciousness is capable capable of
transcending and unifying the
multiplicity into oneness now the
symbolism of hierarchy I've just
described the mountain the ladder is
also the root of why we identify the
highest things with spirit air wind or
with intelligence why we identify the
highest of high with heaven that which
is so high above us that it is
unreachable the father Light spoken word
which comes both from intelligence but
most immediately from the head of the
body so it's not that God is physically
in heaven no reasonable Christian
believes that but rather the analogy of
our experience of heaven of Ascension is
the root the support so to speak for
that which is beyond and cannot be
described directly so hopefully that's
clear enough but I still haven't shown
you how that works I want to go back and
read the comment that I was sent in and
hopefully I can show you
so our commentator says quote I am an
atheist because my pure and honest
desire to understand the universe led me
to answers from biology physics and
other scientific fields these answers
are most sublime and precious than
anything I know notice she says these
answers are more sublime and precious
now what is that word sublime it's an
interesting word because something
sublime is something which is elevated
the source of the notion of sublimation
was the change of a solid into a vapor
so is that what she means that that that
the scientific answers are literally
like changing a solid into a vapor of
course not what she means is that
scientific answers are more precious she
said it rarer something like the move
from the large quantity at the base of
the mountain to the rarer and rarer and
more sought-after summit what sublime
means is that scientific answers are
more like heaven
ie vapor and less like earth ie
solid quote I believe religions and
symbolism can confer meaning in one's
personal subjective life because I've
been on that path before you could say
that is enough because all we have in
our existence is our subjective point of
view but I believe it's a noble act to
care less about that and to desire to
know what happens with the universe
outside your own personal life then how
could anyone judge you for being an
atheist when science isn't perfect as it
is brought you knowledge about distant
stars and galaxies the small world of
atoms and much more now this is where we
need to pay attention the mysticism and
religion did not enlighten us about
matters above subjective and social
aspects now notice again that she uses
the word above now does she mean that
for example that if I had a stack you
know of scientific data like a pile of
paper let's say that I would place it on
top of a stack of subjective and social
matters no obviously not what she's
saying is that there is a hierarchy of
value a mountain
of meaning and scientific knowledge is
in her opinion closer to heaven closer
to the oneness of the summit and that's
really interesting because the
scientific method is by its own
admission by its own process a removal
of all hair keys of value it is the
leveling of the world into measurable
phenomena the removal of all meaning yet
in order to express the superiority of
science
our commentator must resort to the same
language the same structure we use to
say that God the absolute the one the
origin of all multiplicity is in heaven
so what is fascinating is that she can
use that structure of heaven and
hierarchy unconsciously exactly because
the scientific method does not include
it in its worldview does not take it
into consideration how we exist and how
we encounter the world she said it
herself quote it is a noble act to care
less about our subjective point of view
and to desire to know what happens in
the universe outside your own personal
life unquote so she is criticizing
symbolic language while using the
symbolic language to elevate to magnify
and submit herself to science and it's
precious sublime answers but the
language of elevation of hierarchy being
indeed the manner in which we describe
we ascribe value to things is the
religious hierarchy that we find in
Dante or in Jacob's Ladder or in Moses
is the scent of the mountain
the great chain of being as it has been
called it goes unnoticed even as it is
being used creating a form of cognitive
dissonance an unconsciousness of
language and of one's own embodied human
existence you know I used to think that
atheists that when atheists proclaimed
their allegiance to the to the Flying
Spaghetti Monster that they were just
joking but now I'm starting to think
that because they elevate the scientific
process that they elevate something
which is itself a deny denial of any
elevation that maybe they do worship
something at least akin to the Spaghetti
Monster because they don't understand
that analogies of hierarchy are coherent
that we move from the specific to the to
the specific and quantifiable which is
what science attempts to describe you
know dig that trench carry those guns to
the origin of existence the purpose win
that battle win the war the purpose
which is also the capacity to even see
to even consider specific and
quantifiable things we move from the
feet to the head from the earth to the
spirit from the children to the father
from the darkness to the light and all
religious images are completely coherent
as they place themselves on the
hierarchy of be
but if one thinks that earth is more
sublime that quantity is more precious
that descriptions of facts are above
their meanings and the purpose of why
we're describing those facts and not
others well someone who is able to
inhabit unconsciously such an
upside-down inverted world can put
anything at the top of that hierarchy
and I guess the Flying Spaghetti Monster
will do so when our commentator says
quote I will cease being an atheist and
become spiritual or whatever when all
these pretty post hoc connections and
symbols will make a difference in
allowing me to understand the nature of
the universe outside my insignificant
tiny life unquote all I can say is this
you are already spiritual you've told me
yourself it's only that you're trying to
throw mud up in the air throw mud up
into the heavens in the hope and you can
then worship